la roi de ma vieille tati là il ya eu
une opération de la gorge alors bien on
va pas chercher la voie monsieur breux
attire lahti où est ma voix
[Musique]
m
et
je tiens
[Musique]
dans la
c'est
[Musique]
m
aujourd'hui vous emmener avec moi au
lancement d'un smartphone de gaming
c'est le black shark dehors excusez moi
j'ai un peu perdu ma voix black stars de
ça se passe là bas on va parler de ça
d'ailleurs c'est super intéressant je
crois si vous avez suivi dans les
smartphones de gaming évolue énormément
c'est un marché qui qui se développent
le blagueur et faut savoir que c'était
blacks chassent et une société dans
laquelle a investi schumi donc on a
souvent dit j'ai envie de bien que sharp
mais c'est vraiment la kia aujourd'hui
c'est la v2 intéressante ya plein de
nouveautés on n'a pas
il
vous
[Musique]
en fait je suis assez beau ouais ça
allez salut à tous ce monsieur bré est
malade il est là plus de voix il est un
peu ça voilà donc du coup je tends la
vidéo à sa place et on va parler du
black chef de du coup on a un téléphone
purement gaming donc on a vraiment tout
ce qui se fait de mieux en terme de
puissance 1 donc on à la dragon 855 avec
8 giga de mémoire vive et samarie giga
apprend le stockage et les mêmes
versions pour les plus divers de trou de
12 giga avec 512 de mémoire interne
vraiment impressionnant c'est lorsqu'il
la batterie qui file de 156 à qui sait
pas quand il parle à 256
et tata suzanne et l'attenté à la vérité
moi aurait le pot en plus il en soit
parfait à wild fait vraiment des départs
je suis en visionnement du champagne
voilà quarante ans les stagiaires
devraient pas faire de vidéos que j'ai
vécue par fabien
tout leur est bon qu'ils disent marque
gamer 10e
grosse autonomie a donc on a mis quatre
mille intérieur ça je suis un peu déçu
je m'attendais un peu quand même pas au
québec
là c'est vraiment à faire une mise sur
la puissance du coût 4 me c'est quand
même impressionnant mais bon bonne c'est
aimer ça
brassant ya des exceptions qui sont
vendus avec donc du coup on a droit à
des manettes pour transformer le
smartphone comme une mini foot et
cochet on a même un petit parti l'acteur
derrière avec water co l'insee
j'vais ventilateur on à l'écran est
plutôt lumineux ses voeux l'aide a eu
l'info en tout cas il ya une chose qui
passe la paillade immigration plus
l'écran impressionnant
le panneau autour habitants
ils ont fait un espèce de pardon welcome
et
ils ont fait un espèce de
trois des tâches en mieux c'est quand
vous touchez vous naviguez vous appuyez
pas que ça va chauffer sur un pib g
c'est un peu l'idée du tout quoi c'est
ça pour ce qui est du prix de 549 pour
la version bulgare avec 128 mo de
mémoire interne et celui dont 649 pour
la version 12 giga de ram et 250
doit-on toujours été là sur les fichiers
way he voyez là c'est ma voix c'est
jackson ma voix est louis et vous
couvrir jackson sur
remail au lundi sur 226 et aurait
également pu rester connecté dirait que
tu dirais moi j'ai plus de voix et oui
beaucoup
abonnez-vous sont restés connectés c'est
une petite chienne voilà voilà voilà
restez connectés mais vous n'êtes pas
obligés parce que vous pouvez aussi
jouer en wireless avec les les manettes
avec le téléphone qui lui est branché
sur la télé et c'est génial parce que
comme ça vous n'êtes pas connecté
voilà merci jeunes
[Musique]
news about you like you feel the
differences between fins pêcheurs
[Musique]
rens
m la saison des world series
mais pas au hockey
jeremy
camille pin systems and services
notre pipeline france looses
your brain and survival
anaïs note sur mon iphone
[Musique]
c'est andy pollack times
ma connaissance le jeu steam
le fond tout le monde
match correct
l'acteur comme chacun
brenda
trop fort qui va s en faut mais cède
alors aux rideaux baissés à
le secteur
pas de casque
un prêtre jeu
and the price is very interesting veut
échoppes basses
oui
le network et mac os x pire les
accolades
la chope ok c'est bon là c'est le bordel
je vais chercher la voix de monsieur
creux au revoir monsieur dreux voix de
monsieur droite et où ce que tu peux
aller voir aux toilettes
peut-être que j'ai perdu là bas oui ou
peut-être au fond des rois de ma vieille
tati là il ya eu une opération de la
gorge
alors viens on va pas chercher la voie
monsieur breux attire lahti où est ma
voix et où la voix sk mavo là dedans
non non qui a pas mal on va les voir là
bas tu es parti aux toilettes
la voix de monsieur greu alors au
traditionnel bain du mas voilà je ne
sais pas c'est quoi ça fait tout rêve à
crouy c'est vrai bonjour madame
on cherche la voix de monsieur bruno ce
que vous l'auriez ok on va continuer de
chercher alors la voix de monsieur
grenouille je crois qu'on la trouvera
pas aujourd'hui bon alors ce qu'on voit
et ce qui est intéressant avec ce
smartphone j de récupérer un peu ma voix
c'est un peu compliqué on voulait pas
trop parler doucement si tu te demander
un gros truc donc huit mois ce qui est
cool c'est qu'on va que les smartphones
dans l'univers du gaming se multipliant
ce n'est pas le premier coup d'essai de
blackjack c'est deuxième gaou de la csac
un black shark 2 est d'ailleurs sur
l'autre tout le blackjack un dur à dire
la tiare qu'un avait été numéro un au
niveau du clac encore franchement très
longtemps comme ça c'est cool
est ce qu'on voit est ce qui est
intéressant ce qu'il faudrait pour tenir
de l'adn de ce black jack
c'est que en fait et ce qui compte le
site
c'est pas que le smartphone dans
l'humaine le smartphone en lui-même il
est il intéressant et l'important m qui
est vachement important
giresse et les accessoires vous allez
avoir avec la manette peut-être pouvoir
transformer le fait
brancher à votre écran et 40 petite
manette pour jouer avec le fait d'avoir
du refroidissement on accessoires voir
en 10 secondes vous allez lui emmener je
sais pas combien de rire enfin tout est
vraiment hyper intéressant alors tout ça
bien sûr qu'on sera à venir parler parce
qu'on ne testera ce produit comme ça je
pourrais vraiment vous dire ce que j'en
pense et comment je trouve en tout cas
ce qu'on voit et il est hyper steak est
un steak et c'est normal c'est le
qualcomm snapdragon 155 vous en doutez
il ya beaucoup de ram 8 giga drame tout
j viendra mais fois c'est une grosse
grosse grosse machine mais ce qui est
cool en tout cas il faut vraiment
retenir aujourd'hui c'est des
smartphones gaming qui continue à se
développer
les gaming et les gamer c'est plus en
plus c'est cool c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs je pas si vous êtes un gamer
c'est ça vous botte si vous avez déjà le
black shark un peu le parquet en
commentaire pièces que vous trouvez que
le fait d'avoir un smartphone de gaming
c'est un sens ça vous plaît oui non quoi
comment vous invite à marquer tout ça en
bas en commentaire et bien évidemment à
visionner ma playlist par là où par là
avec tous les smartphones et au bon
voilà je vous embrasse
je retourne repose et va voir parce que
demain j'ai un truc très important donc
voilà tout ce que vous proposez voilà
silence pas faire de bruit